[Aplausos]
[Música]
a única coisa que nós temos certeza hoje
é que a mudança é um fato
ao longo de toda a nossa história da
humanidade a gente conviveu com a
mudança
então o que a gente tem a observar sobre
isso porque é que tudo muda o tempo
inteiro né como a música do lulu santos
fala pra gente porque nós somos seres
que são movidos pelo ímpeto de procurar
coisas novas de criar soluções para os
problemas com os quais nós vivemos é de
que queria construir uma melhoria
melhoria de vida qualidade de vida de
ter o diferente à nossa volta
transformar o ambiente e isso é que faz
de nós seres empreendedores
por isso a criatividade aliada à nossa
capacidade de materialização faz com que
a gente consiga criar processos
empreendedores de inovação
isso vai se refletir desde lá os
primórdios quando houve a invenção da
roda
até hoje a gente lidando com a
nanotecnologia se não fossem esses
processos inovadores movidos pela nossa
característica empreendedora né o perfil
empreendedor está vendo de cada um de
nós
a gente só precisa trabalhar isso e se
não fosse isso não seria possível a
gente ter transformado o mundo e hoje
está aqui pra discutir um tema como
economia 4.0 indústria 4.0 e tudo que
elas envolvem também no nosso
comportamento social
então quando a gente fala de inovação é
importante a gente pensar o seguinte o
que que é informação
qual é a idéia de inovação muita gente
acha que inovar é você tem idéia
é você ser criativo mas não é bem isso
passa um pouco desse tema
ainda na primeira metade do século 20
júpiter trouxe pra gente um economista
austríaco ia vamos dizer assim foi o
pioneiro em estudar esse fenômeno
ele traz pra gente o conceito de que a
inovação é na verdade a motriz para a
geração de riqueza dentro dos negócios
que as empresas que conseguiam se
apropriar processos de inovação de
tecnologia é na produção em seus
processos ganhando otimização de
recursos comercializando produtos novos
essas empresas tinham ganho tremendo de
competitividade e com isso poderiam ter
também um ganho exponencialmente nos
seus resultados
quando a gente fala sobre ganhos
exponenciais ao agente já estavam
vivendo esse momento em que pensar
exponencialmente o mercado substituiu o
antigo modelo em que a gente pensava
apenas em retorno financeiro ou
lucratividade ou mesmo liderança de
mercado
esses são conceitos antigos que não
pertencem mais ao mundo de hoje
então hoje quando a gente fala e
economia 4.0
a gente está falando que não é mais um
diferencial você inovar é simplesmente
sobrevivência é premissa das empresas
não incorporarem essa necessidade de
estar sempre revendo seus próximos
criando novas tendências novas
tecnologias e quando eu falo tecnologia
eu não estou falando só da parte de
informática é que a gente está
acostumado muita social inovação com
tecnologia mas quando você fala de
tecnologia hoje você
o ano praticamente de uma commodity o
que importa é o que você vai fazer com
essa tecnologia que movimentos
transformadores você vai poder gerar né
então a tecnologia ela tem que estar a
serviço do que o da inovação de produto
da inovação de processo e sobretudo hoje
da inovação nos modelos de negócio a
gente observando os ciclos econômicos
a gente vai ver que eles vão se dá em
função das revoluções industriais
a gente teve quatro momentos a gente
está vendo a quarta agora de revolução
industrial ea gente observa a tui
círculos econômicos que são movidos
pelas ondas de inovação
eles têm cinco estados cada vez mais mês
gráfico aqui a gente consegue é um pouco
cheio de coisas mas são coisas
importantes para a gente entender a
gente vem aqui da linha azul para
vermelha que a gente tem aqui a o grau
de complexidade e essas tecnologias não
envolver
então cada vez mais as revoluções e as
ondas de inovação trazendo um grau de
complexidade maior
a gente observa que nós temos aqui um
século mais ou menos separando cada uma
dessas revoluções até a terceira que é
um marco que a gente vai falar um
pouquinho dela depois e agora que a
gente tem em 2011 cunhada na alemanha
já o conceito de revolução de quarta
revolução industrial
em cada um desses movimentos a gente vai
ver uma onda de inovação gerada
só que observa aqui a gente tem a onda
de inovação acompanhando o movimento da
revolução industrial e tão sujo
na inglaterra a explosão é da primeira
revolução muito baseada em cima ainda da
energia hidráulica do vapor e da questão
da indústria têxtil fazendo ali é todo
um movimento econômico na segunda onda a
gente começa até aquele conceito
fordista né que a gente tem a produção
em massa começa a acontecer a produção
em massa aqui ea gente vai ter na
verdade um quase que uma compensação em
crescer círculos de revolução com a
ordem na na terceira onda o que a gente
vai observar aqui você já começa a
entrar dentro do mesmo ciclo de inovação
então a gente tem aqui a terceira onda
já se manifestando dentro do mesmo
círculo de revolução o que isso quer
dizer
isso quer dizer que a economia está
mudando com mais velocidade que o
mercado está mudando com mais velocidade
na quarta na terceira onda ou desculpa
na quarta onda de inovação onde a gente
já tem aqui o petróleo completamente
introduzido a evolução da eletrônica da
aviação a gente está falando aqui olha
1950 1951 ainda tá na era da venda nem a
gente ainda tem a comunicação de massa a
produção de massa e aqui é
representativamente um momento em que a
gente rompe com isso tudo porque entra
aqui
já a quinta onda no ano 2000 um
pouquinho antes que é a parte onde a
dominância de software cti de automação
vão fazer toda a diferença ea gente sai
ainda nesta revolução a gente sai
completamente dessa parte de produção de
massa ea gente vai para a customização
a gente vai falar sobre um outro tipo de
relação com
consumo e com o mercado e as empresas
precisam estar antenados para fazer essa
transformação
a base da tecnologia passa a ser todo um
diferencial pra você desenhar os seus
modelos de negócio e para você conseguir
se comunicar com o seu consumidor entra
aqui a questão do facebook a néon é onde
surgem aquelas primeiras empresas de
tecnologia que vão fazer redes sociais
que vão fazer toda uma transformação no
comportamento nos relacionamentos
humanos também não só na questão é
comercial mas no dia a dia na forma da
gente se relacionar
quando a gente fala desse momento que a
gente vive agora né onde a gente está na
4ª revolução industrial que é aquela
aquele momento em que a gente tem
tecnologias que vão propiciar sistemas
integrados de inteligência dentro da
indústria a gente tem uma sexta onda mas
já estamos com a sexta onda dino de
inovação e com um ciclo muito mais curto
aqui a gente já tem outras questões
completamente diferentes né como a
bíblia a biomimética que é você se
apropriar de forma da biologia né do
estudo de de questões da biologia para
você utilizar na sua tecnologia no seu
mercado energia limpa indústria verde e
por aí vai
mas hoje uma coisa nesse meio tempo que
foi fundamental e se não tivesse
acontecido isso talvez a gente não
tivesse conseguido evoluir e fazer tanta
diferença de um momento para o outro
quando a gente fala de economia que foi
a banda larga
o advento da banda larga que se dá nesse
momento em que a gente está é vivendo a
era digital
ele faz uma diferença tremenda porque
ele simplesmente faz com que a gente
fique conectado o
o tempo inteiro então quando a gente
está conectado o tempo todo a gente faz
com que as empresas fazem com a gente o
tempo inteiro a gente pode dar feedback
a gente tem uma outra forma de
comercializar
eu não vou mais simplesmente ter que
esperar um momento pra é tá no meu
computador e me conectar lembram daquela
rede de escada
não sei se todos aqui vivenciaram esse
momento mas era uma coisa difícil da
gente conviver estava toda a vida aquele
negócio de scanner fazendo barulho
ensurdecedor e não trava nunca gente a
banda larga o mundo veio para o nosso
celular acabou é essa distância né eu
posso fazer o que eu quiser
onde eu estiver beijo na operação
financeira no internet banking da vida
né
como fazer uma compra de qualquer
produto que esteja disponível em como
esse me comunicar com os meus amigos
enfim estudar qualquer coisa hoje pode
ser feita de qualquer lugar
a partir desse movimento aqui isso fazer
gente a gente prestar atenção aqui olha
só a gente tem toda uma indústria
imobilizada que veio migrando ao longo
dos tempos ea gente chegou aqui em 2017
com as maiores empresas sendo todos de
tecnologia
então o que significa isso
a inversão de valores que foi feita todo
o processo econômico hoje quando a gente
é falta de saulo eixo de uma empresa
seja precificação de mercado de uma
empresa a gente tem aí uma elevação
muito grande de coisas de bens e de
valores que são completamente diferentes
do que acontecia lá no início eu trouxe
aqui também pra vocês um exemplo que é
bem interessante que é um gráfico que
mostra a
maiores startup de tecnologia vejam já é
um movimento diferente daquele gráfico
anterior
ali eu tinha as empresas com maior valor
e china que eu tô falando das estar
táxis são empresas que não têm 10 anos
de vida
imagina essas empresas surgiram com
modelos de negócios inovadores e
diferenciados
a gente tem uma relação completamente
diferente com elas do que com aquelas
outras que eu mostrei né
no outro bloco e elas são e as empresas
de tecnologia mais valiosas hoje rubber
68 bilhões é a maior empresa a gente tem
aqui observo um detalhe
china e estados unidos
apenas bom
é importante a gente falar também que a
internet das coisas
a big data de centralização ea fábrica
inteligentes são movimentos que vão
marcar essa indústria 4.0 essas 72 dias
elas propiciaram toda essa transformação
que a gente está vivendo agora
bom assim a minha mochila se comunicou
comigo da honra já tiver através de um
sensor eu consigo rastrear eu consigo
identificar se tenha uma vaga na rua ao
lado porque eu tô ligado num aplicativo
que tem um sensor na outra rua e traz
isso pra mim todas essas formas de eu
mudar a minha comunicação com as
empresas vai fazer com que outros
serviços surjam vai fazer com que a
gente demande novas é tendência de um
modelo de negócio e é importante
entender isso
se eu sou empresário hoje não basta
simplesmente fica olhando o fluxo de
caixa da minha empresa
esse movimento já foi
eu tenho que me preocupar em como eu vou
crescer exponencialmente
aqui tem um exemplo da impressão 3d
então vocês vejam um coração de silicone
funciona e é colocado nas pessoas
durante o processo de transfusão
desintermediação inteligência artificial
proposta de valor realidade aumentada
esses termos já fazem parte do nosso dia
a dia
quando a gente fala em desenho e
desintermediação de negócios
eu tô falando eu dê liga o fornecedor
diretamente ao cliente pense sobre isso
como eu posso desenhar o meu negócio de
forma a atender o cliente sem
intermediação a tendência do que ele
quer né com proposta de valor como que
eu posso trabalhar isso pra atender o
mercado o que essas pessoas têm
realmente na sua cabeça e aqui tá
talvez a fórmula que fale um pouco sobre
essas tendências
o desculpa a gente tem aqui a economia
3.0 e a 4.0 e eu coloquei algumas itens
que vão fazer essa diferença aqui a
gente falava de consumismo ea gente
ainda faz um discurso
o consumismo crescente né o quanto que
as pessoas consomem hoje quando a gente
vai pensar no mundo atual já não é
futuro ao mundo de agora a gente tem que
pensar em consumerismo ou seja eu quero
usufruir
eu não quero ter o bem então é um novo
movimento que surge como que eu vou
atender a essa nova geração que não se
preocupa e ter mais em viver
experiências em usufruir em poder
compartilhar das coisas produção em
escala produção escala hoje está sendo
completamente substituída pela
manufatura do tipo vocês viram a
impressora 3d lá fora viram aquela capaz
de fazer até reduzindo o custo em
grandes estruturas até prédios você já
pode fazer com a empresa os preços de
então até na
a construção civil a gente já tem isso
como realidade hoje customização a gente
vai ter a questão da cocriação surgindo
então eu não vou simplesmente entendeu
que o meu consumidor quer
eu vou trazer o consumidor para
participar do meu negócio
a gente tem uma mudança que é radical
aqui olha empregabilidade e trabalha
habilidade é uma palavra esquisita
devemos confessar mas é uma palavra que
diz muito sobre essa mudança do mercado
o que o mercado está esperando
hoje as pessoas não têm mais que ter uma
cabeça de que vão conseguir um emprego e
vão trabalhar naquela empresa durante
anos e vão fazer uma carreira ali você
tem que ter a capacidade de se colocar
para projetos
você tem que ter a capacidade de
empreender de se movimentar entregas
é isso que o mercado está demandando as
próprias empresas estão pedindo esse
tipo de atitude na hora de contratar as
empresas também estão querendo em
funcionários colaboradores que sejam
entre empreendedores que façam essa
diferença então é importante a gente
ficar com a seguinte mensagem o futuro
não vai acontecer
ele já está acontecendo a cada instante
a instante tudo pode mudar ea gente tem
que ter essa noção porque essa disrupção
que vai fazer com que a gente possa
elaborar novos negócios e novas formas
da gente atingiu o mercado e de ter esse
doente potencial que a gente tanto rude
obrigado
[Aplausos]